how much does floyd mayweather own you
oh yeah
how much can you tell us how much
starting off strong huh yep uh millions
like
over five no i don't think so
over probably probably just under five
over two yeah wow
whoa
like enough for me to
like pay me my [ __ ] money you know
like
how can he do that i don't
it's not held in escrow or some [ __ ]
okay all right uh
uh
floyd mayweather has been boxing forever
he knows how to allocate money really
conveniently to make it look like it's
an expense he knows how to do under the
table deals cash deals using my name and
likeness without telling me he's using
my name in likeness
he's actually being sued for it there's
a lawsuit actually in this state new
york happening right now
he's being sued for
he took i think 10 million dollars cash
under the table or something with like
ticketing or something and oh oh i heard
about it he sold the rights he sold to
like qatar or some [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah where's my [ __ ] cut yeah cause
you're getting a percentage you use me
yeah
and so the the to finish what i'm saying
is uh are you are you a slave is that
like yeah
[Laughter]
if you're telling me to chalk it up
he thinks he can do what he wants
because you know i i'm new to the boxing
game yeah um
nah we'll see you in court bucko wow but
that's the [ __ ] up thing is you could
end up spending
two million in court four million in
court and then
i guess maybe he would have to pay that
is the [ __ ] up thing i don't know dude
like how many how many lawsuits can pile
up regarding one event before you you
have to make amends
like mine will be the second for the
same event hmm
[Applause]
floyd money maybe they ain't got no
money dude
is that true yeah yeah is he broke yeah
no he's not broke but he's on his way if
he doesn't continue doing these [ __ ]
exhibition fights you see the one he
just did yeah where he fought it was uh
fought his training from the middle east
yeah he fought this guy by the name of
don moore i think yeah
and like he just he beat him up he
knocked him down he beat him up they
went eight rounds but like i don't know
man i i the whole the whole floyd thing
was weird like on paper that fight never
should have happened and it did yeah and
then i lasted eight rounds and like
pieced him up a little bit he's on my
highlight reel floyd mayweather's on my
highlight reel okay i'm not gonna go
piss them off but i am gonna say you hit
him with one overhand right that hurt
him that's how my highlight really hurt
cause there's no decision no it was up
to him he said there's no decision in
the fight right he's like it's not going
to the cards he he he guaranteed the
viewers that there would be a knockout
on june 6. yeah not only was it not a
knockout yeah but i popped his eardrum
that's the one in my highlight reel oh
did you actually pop his hair yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i don't know if he went to the hospital
but a hundred percent fact popped his
eardrum
his
one person on his team al doesn't want
to believe it
how does
[Laughter]
this is the this is the guy who can't be
hit right this is the ghost he's the
greatest fighter of all time a youtuber
has no business no he's never hit him or
like at real content i shouldn't ever
give you that you shouldn't have touched
them and not even close
i won rounds not one night
not not now
i got it
i got to give it up to your brother
because jake you know jake is a
scientific dude
immediately after the fight the cameras
right now he goes eight rounds to
nothing
logan you just
[Music]
he was being a little delusional yeah
but like dog
at least i won three rounds facts
we were watching that fight no you were
not you don't think that i ordered that
fight
bro i'm texting my boys like oh boy's
just warming them up
i put money that i want at least three
rounds yo better believe it
floyd floyd was my goat bro i'll be
honest with you and this and he he dm me
once right and he was like listen thank
you for the nice things that you said
about me and because he listened to a
rogan episode and he didn't get to the
part where i started making fun of his
his hair
and [ __ ] like that and then i responded
and then like nothing so immediately
after that i was like okay he's like a
little sensitive i still hadn't thought
you had no [ __ ] chance
and you didn't beat him wait wait let me
ask you this yeah yeah
all right i want to ask
yeah you're [ __ ] delusional
you are delusional
[Music]
bro you think he won seven rounds
i didn't say seven i didn't say
he said how many
i think i think how many
i gave him one more then the fight was
there he did one more because he won the
arbitration right
[Laughter]
i gotta run it back
i gotta run back
yo low-key like the fact that you
touched him is enough reason to not
fight back this is no but now i'm
dissatisfied you've you've from just
upset me
don't might be dead
[Laughter]
my record would say that yeah you can't
take me
i have no way
we could see though right we could try
it out
he thinks he can [ __ ] up legit anyway
guys oh you let me train for a guy okay
wait hold on a second
thing it was him then he took it she
read about it i was gonna say you look
like black willy wonka but you know but
come to my talk to faculty
he wants
[Laughter]
but logan's kind of big when you meet
him in person yeah he is yeah people say
that i get this feedback yeah i get this
feedback now but i'm still a [ __ ] make
no mistake
hold on
what do you mean by you're still
you'll get in there and you'll swing no
it's sarcastic okay
no i wouldn't
do this